traue keinem garten in dem kein unkraut
wächst kennst du den spruch den hätte
ich am anfang meiner garten karriere
noch eins zu eins so unterschrieben aber
mittlerweile mache ich das nicht mehr
unser garten ist nämlich fast komplett
unkrautfrei und wie das funktioniert auf
ganz natürliche art und weise
unkrautvernichtungsmittel oder
irgendwelche plastikfolien das zeige ich
euch heute in diesem video
[Musik]
falls du dich noch nicht kennst ich bin
marie ich gebe kurse rund um das thema
selbstversorgung aus dem garten hier auf
dem youtube-kanal spreche ich auch ganz
viele beides thema gemüsegarten also
abonniere gerne meinen kanal und drücke
auch die glocke wenn du informiert
werden möchtest sobald das nächste video
erscheint ja was ist an unkraut denn
überhaupt so schlecht daran dass erst
mal überhaupt nicht schlecht in meinen
gemüsebeeten möchte ich aber möglichst
wenig unkraut haben weil die unkräuter
oder auch bei kräuter wildkräuter wie
auch immer man sie nennen mag immer in
konkurrenz mit den gemüsepflanzen treten
die ja möglichst viel platz haben sollen
in den beeten die möglichst groß und
kräftig werden sollen und die unkräuter
konkurrieren um licht um nährstoffe um
wasser mit den gemüsepflanzen deswegen
bin ich der überzeugung dass es gut ist
möglichst wenig um kräuter im b zu haben
die können gerne über alle im restlichen
garten wachsen und sprießen und ich
freue mich da auch sehr darüber
vor allem über seltene wildkräuter über
heilkräuter und so weiter aber meine
beete sollen möglichst unkrautfrei
bleiben das erspart ihnen nämlich super
viel arbeit ich mag es nicht gerne auf
den knien durch die beete zu haben und
unkraut zu jäten
ich glaube da sind wir uns einig und
dadurch das unser garten unkraut freies
bat mir das immens viel zeit ich arbeite
vollzeit im büro ich habe einen kleinen
sohn ich studiere ökologische
landwirtschaft und hab auch noch viele
andere hobbys und sachen die ich gerne
in meiner freizeit mache und deswegen
finde ich es super schön wenn mein
garten möglichst pflegeleicht ist und
wenn man nicht mehr jede muss dann
erspart einem das so so so viel arbeit
ich weiß noch wie das vorher war bevor
ich diese techniken die ich euch heute
zeige angewendet habe
da war meine gebete ständig zu gebucht
hat und ich kam überhaupt nicht mehr
hinterher das war einfach kein schönes
gefühl ich hatte irgendwann keine lust
mehr auf meinen garten und jetzt
passiert das nicht mehr weil quasi kaum
noch unkraut europa weiterhin fällt also
ich glaube mit drei minuten hätten im
monat kommen die dicke hin
und wie das funktioniert das zeige ich
euch jetzt der hauptgrund warum meinen
daten unkrautfrei ist ist dass ich meine
bete nicht um grabe das hat ganz
unterschiedliche gründe zum einen kann
er natürlich gewachsener gartenboden in
den natürlichen schichtung was sehr viel
besser speichern es wenn man das stört
dann gefördert es auch das bodenleben
wenn man nehmen die bodenschichten
unberührt lässt bzw es tötet
lieben wenn man umgräbt dass es in den
biogarten auch super wichtig damit er
möglichst fruchtbar ist wenn die
bodenlebewesen einfach als kleine helfer
im boden braucht erspart super viel
arbeit wenn man nicht um graben muss ich
hasse umgraben ist es super anstrengend
so möchte ich das sparen können aber es
hat eben auch noch den grund dass im
gartenboden ist natürlich mutterboden
ein quasi unerschöpfliches potenzial an
unkrautsamen enthalten ist und wenn du
um krebs dann denkst du zwar deine
unkräuter die jetzt auf der in beeten
wachsen mit erde und schaufelt die unter
aber du hast wieder ganz viele neue
unkrautsamen und wurzel und kräuter an
die oberfläche die da anwachsen so weit
nicht hinkommt und ruckzuck sind deine
beete wieder total vertraut wird und das
zu unterbrechen und um den boden
natürlich aufzubauen und zu schonen und
zu schützen
gärtner rege ich komplett ohne umgraben
ich lege meine beete mit pappe und mit
kompost also erstmal nicht papa auf den
beeten aus bringen die nicht bedruckt
ist die nicht irgendwelche klebereste
enthält und dann bringe ich da auf
kompost aus und so kann man super
fruchtbare beete anlegen wie das ganz
genau funktioniert zeige ich euch zum
beispiel in meinem gemüsegarten bootcamp
da könnt ihr euch gerne kostenlos für
anmelden das ist ein kleiner mini video
kurs den ich für euch erstellt habe den
link findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung da zeige ich schritt für
schritt wie man diese combo später
anlegt die sind im ersten jahr schon
super fruchtbar und die bleiben
jahrelang nahezu unkrautfrei oft hat man
das problem wenn man kompost im
gemüsegarten ausbringt dass man damit
ganz viele unkrautsamen und wurzel und
kräuter wieder auf den beeten verteilt
die man vorher geäst und auf dem kompost
entsorgt hat deswegen entsorge ich und
heute jeglicher art wenn sie bei uns
dann mal anfallen
in einem separaten haufen gehen habe ich
irgendwo in der garten ecke da schmeiße
ich das dann immer drauf da entsteht
dann auch nach und nach einen kompost
und den bringe ich dann nur unter den
beerensträuchern und den obstbäumen aus
und meine haut kompost den ich hier an
den gemüsebeeten habe
der bleibt komplett unkrautfrei wenn du
doch unkräuter über dein haupt kompost
entsorgen möchtest dann kannst du dafür
sorgen dass die kompostierung möglichst
heiß verläuft es erreicht man indem man
den stickstoff anteil im komposthaufen
erhöht und das ganze richtig oft umsetzt
dann entstehen der richtig heiße
temperaturen die unkräuter ab
das wäre natürlich auch eine option ich
mache das einfach so dass sich die
unkräuter separat entsorge und dadurch
mein kompost komplett unkrautfrei bleibt
das ist natürlich super wichtig weil
sonst kann man sich das hier hätte nach
behandle man die sachen aus reist
kompostiert und dann einfach wieder aus
bringt auf den beeten dann bringt das ja
nicht so wirklich
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich könnt ihr euch vorstellen
wenn man nicht mehr geld muss dann ist
der garten gleich vier viel
pflegeleichter wenn ihr noch mehr tipps
wollt wie man einen gemüsegarten
pflegeleicht gestalten kann
dann schaut euch gerne dieses video oder
oben an das war linke ich euch gerne da
zeige ich euch wie wir schaffen das wir
nur drei stunden gartenarbeit in der
woche unser obst und gemüse fast
komplett selber anbauen
das kann ich euch sehr empfehlen das
video da oben der nächste große tipp die
du möglichst unkrautfrei gärtnern kannst
ist milch also eine organische abdeckung
die du auf deinem boden um die pflanzen
herum aus bringst und die den boden
bedeckt hält das sorgt dafür dass da
kein licht mehr dran kommt und dass
selbst wenn in der im kompost oder in
deinem buch noch unkrautsamen enthalten
sind die nicht aufgehen können und auch
so kleine viele um kräuter wie löwenzahn
ich weiß einige werden jetzt diskutieren
dass man löwenzahn ja auch wunderbar
setzen kann
aber wie gesagt in meinem beten mag ich
ihn nicht haben dass die in den beeten
mich wurzeln können weil die nur auf die
mulchschicht treffen da können die
lampen aber darin können die ja keine
wurzeln bin davon können wir ja nicht
aufgehen deswegen denke ich meine bitte
immer immer immer mit ganz viel milch ab
dafür nehme ich am liebsten
holzhackschnitzel ich neben auch
rasenschnitt stroh kann man neben laub
kann man eben alles mögliche was im
garten an organischem material anfällt
einfach zwischen den pflanzen verteilen
ich mache da immer eine richtig dicke
mulchschicht die unterdrückt nämlich
auch dann das wasser aus dem boden
verdunste so dass er nebenbei auch kaum
noch wissen müssen wir unseren gehalten
das ist ein wundervoller effekt deswegen
würde ich es jedem jedem jedem ich weiß
ich habe schon so oft gesagt aber ich
würde es jedem empfehlen die beete zum
mulchen das ist auch für das bodenleben
super der mulch verrottet nach und nach
und er gibt noch mehr kompost fördert
das bodenleben ergibt dünger es gibt
tausend gründe warum man seine beete
mission sollte
dafür müsst ihr auf jeden fall
ausprobieren wenn ihr unkrautfrei gern
im wald und dann noch ein tipp falls
doch mal unkräuter in deinem garten
aufgehen sollen
bleib hinterher mit dem gelten solange
die noch klein sind
es ist nämlich überhaupt kein problem
einfach mal mit der hacke durch die
reihen zu gehen und dann ist das ganze
schon wieder erledigt aber wenn die
erstmal größer werden gerade wenn die
samen bilden also wenn die anfangen zu
blühen und samen bilden dann kann aus
einer pflanze schnell mal können ein
paar hundert werden oder sogar tausend
je nachdem was finden um kraut du in
deinem garten hast das solltest du auf
jeden fall vermeiden und dann kannst du
auch gut hinterher bleiben mit dem
letten wenn du einfach regelmäßig
schaust sind da unkräuter aufgegangen
und wenn ja welche sind dann hättest du
dir sofort weg dann hast du wirklich
kein problem mehr dass du so viel
unkraut in deinem garten herrscht so
dass du nicht mehr hinterherkommen ist
also einfach regelmäßig durch die reihen
gehen die deine gemüsebeete anschauen
und sobald da erste unkräuter auftauchen
sofort weg gehen dann hast du wirklich
kein problem das die so groß werden und
die das ganze über den kopf wächst mit
dem ganzen rummel deine gemüsepflanzen
nicht mehr wiederfindet so war das bei
mir am anfang ich bin sehr froh dass wir
das jetzt hingekriegt haben so
unkrautfrei zugehört man einen
pflegeleichten gemüsegarten zu haben
also wenn du lust hast da noch mehr zu
lernen dann praktisch gerne für mein
kostenloses bootcamp 1
da erzähle ich auch noch viel mehr über
das mulchen also mit welchen materialien
wannen vidic und so weiter das ist wie
gesagt kostenlos und der link ist unten
in der video beschreibung ist wenn ihr
noch mehr tipps gegen unkraut im garten
habt dann hinterlasst mir gerne einen
kommentar ich freue mich auch immer neue
sachen zu lernen da trieben verlinke ich
euch nochmal meinen sie wo ich erzähle
wie wir uns in drei stunden komplett mit
gemüse und obst selbst versorgen da
unten findest du auch noch ein
spannendes video und wenn dieses video
hier gefallen hat dann freue ich mich
wenn du meinen daumen nach oben gibt bis
gleich wir sehen uns hoffentlich gleich
da oder da wieder